[موسيقى]
مسلسل الاخبار من قناه الجزيره اهلا بكم
معه اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اطلاق قمر
صناعي عسكري الى الفضاء من جانب اخر قال
رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ان كل يوم يزيد
فيه الغرب وامداد اوكرانيا بالسلاح فانه
يقرب من اندلاع ما سماه الجحيم النووي
اضافه فان خطرا اندلاع حرب نوويه لم
يتراجع بل يتزايد وبخصوص مذكره المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه بتوقيف الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين قال ان توقيف الرئيس الروسي في
الخارج يعادل اعلان الحرب على روسيا
النوويه
قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
العميد بات رايدر ان القوات الامريكيه
تواصل عملياتها فوق البحر الاسود والتحليق
في الاجواء الدوليه بما يراعي القانون
الدولي
ذلك قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكن ان بلاده تستعد لمواجهه تحديين
اولهما مباشر من منافسيها الاستراتيجيين
كروسيا والصين
قال متحدث باسم القياده الامريكيه لمنطقه
الهند والهادئ ان تصريحات الصين بشان
ابعاد مدمره امريكيه من مياهها الاقليميه
كاتبه واكد ان السفينه تقوم بعمليات
روتينيه في بحر جنوب الصين ولم تطرد وكان
الجيش الصيني وقال ان المدمر الامريكيه يو
اس اس ميلس اخترقت بشكل غير قانوني المياه
الاقليميه واضاف ان القوات البحريه
والجويه راقبتها واطلقت انذارات لابعادها
اعرب المنسق الاممي الخاص لعمليه السلام
في الشرق الاوسط تور وينسلاند عن قلقه
ازاء زياده مستويات العنف المرتبطه
بالمستوطنين في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
وحتى خلال جلسه مفتوحه لمجلس الامن بشان
الاوضاع في الشرق الاوسط حتى اسرائيل على
التقيد بالتزاماتها بموجب القانون الدولي
لحمايه الفلسطينيين من جميع اعمال العنف
كما اعربت المندوبه الامريكيه في مجلس
الامن الدولي ليندا توماس كريند فيلد عن
رفض واشنطن لكل اعمال العنف والتحريض
عليها في فلسطين وحثت الاطراف على وقف
التصعيد والامتناع عن الاجراءات الاحاديه
والخطاب غير المفيد الذي يؤدي الى تاجيج
التوترات
ختام المجاز الى اللقاء